média pour les journalistes collabos
c'est très difficile pour un certain
nombre de deux confrères de faire leur
métier par exemple journaliste de bfm tv
ont maintenant une protection
personnelle physique pour aller sur les
ronds-points écouter à titre d'exemple
de cette espèce de défiance la façon
dont un journaliste anonyme qui se dit
journaliste gilet jaune interpelle
c'était lundi dernier notre confrère
jean-michel aphatie à la sortie des
studios dice et ea
moi ce que j'ai vu c'est sur wikipédia
vous avez eu des débuts très modeste
vous étiez cafetiers et maintenant ce
que je vois c'est que vous êtes du côté
des puissants
c'est que on dit mais oui vous êtes du
côté des puissants et savourer palier
quand on prend tous dressent rené
brillet lamont je ne peux rien y ait de
vos accusations
je ne peux rien mais parce que c'est
vrai sur mais voilà c'est pour ça que je
ne peux pas dire parce que les gilets
jaunes sondhi vous êtes la vérité
monsieur est ce que tout ce que vous
vous êtes du côté du mensonge et de la
manipulation tout ce que vous dites est
vrai voilà tout ce que je dis moi est
faux bon comment est ce que je peux nier
quelque chose mais voilà qu est ce que
vous êtes vous un citoyen et moi qu'est
ce que je suis selon votre raisonnement
une mère de celui du canon vous êtes un
millionnaire vous êtes un petit
millionnaire apporté de gros
milliardaire changerait quoi je n'aurais
pas le droit d'être citoyen comme eux
vous rien de toi à titre personnel vous
vous la sentez vous cette cette
hostilité des journalistes envers les
gilet jaune affaires pardon et gilbert
même si l'inversé parfois vrai alors
comment alors nous a mariés on n'a pas
trop senti bien que vous les soutenez
plus tôt on va dire vouloir si on
regarde nos unes c'est effectivement
bateau était en soutien
je pense que c'est aussi une manière de
les approcher il ya quelques semaines on
a fait une grande haussier où on allait
rencontrer des gilets jaunes et ont
passé beaucoup de temps avec eux et on
était allé voilà écoute dans une
une position plutôt d'empathie et
honnêtement ça s'est très bien passé
après c'est vrai qu'il ya une tendance
on sent une vraie méfiance chez beaucoup
de gilet jaune mais je pense qu'il faut
pas trop être corporatiste pour le coup
et que sont évidemment justifier les
violences qui sont inacceptables
la méfiance pour le coup elle peut
justifier parce que si moi par exemple
j'ai jeté un oeil aux autres traitements
à la télévision dans les chaînes d'info
en continu des gilet jaune et je les
trouvais assez défavorables et parfois
même un petit peu mal aux natifs donc je
pense qu'elle peut se comprendre la
méfiance à sa place comment vous
l'expliquez vous cette cette méfiance
voire cette défiance dur est simple je
crois que c'est le reflet déjà d'une
fracture entre une certaine élite
journalistique et les citoyens français
qui qui est déjà ancrée depuis un
certain temps à travers plusieurs
plusieurs sujets dont on a reproché le
traitement médiatique
or ça pouvait être le break site le vote
front national de l'immigration le
mariage pour tous
on avait quand même au sein des
principaux médias
un seul et même son cloche et
aujourd'hui je crois que des
journalistes sans justifier attention
que ce soit clair les violences dont ils
font l'objet
sayah aucune aucune excuse et aucune
justification possible
certains journalistes en fait tu payes
c'est un petit peu le c'est un petit peu
le retour de flamme et on a des médias
des journalistes qui on un certain
comment dire à une espèce de complexe de
supériorité intellectuelle et qui se
heurte aujourd'hui aux français lambda
c'est difficile pour eux je pense que ce
ne serait pas menée avec les jeunes
c'est quelque chose qui s'est installé
ce qui peut à certains égards néanmoins
paraître un peu paradoxal c'est à dire
que les mêmes français qui se plaignent
donc on l'a dit du traitement médiatique
des sujets d'actualité sont aussi ceux
qu'on retrouve devant bfm télé c'est à
dire que bfm là pendant la la la cride
et gilet jaune a fait des records des
records d'audience je me suis d'ailleurs
elle sait il ya beaucoup progresser nous
également tout à fait beaucoup de
chaînes et donc c'est un petit peu
paradoxal c'est à dire que quand vous
demandez
un français qui regrette un petit peu
les journaux la presse
quel est le dernier journal que tu as
acheté et y en a pas en fait
donc il faut aussi se donner les moyens
de cette presse que l'on souhaite être
indépendantes ou plurielle et ça passe
forcément à un moment par la main à la
poche
il ya plein de petits médias
indépendants des revues le comptoir
social traités etc qui n'ont pas
forcément le lecteur et si on se tourne
vers les grandes chaînes mais quelque
part c'était le prix à payer dans la
facilité daniel bilalian vous avez été
l'un des patrons de la télévision
publique française vous avez déjà connu
ce genre de situation
non pas du tout je pense que ce
phénomène là malheureusement j'ai une
certaine ancienneté dans la profession
ce phénomène là il est dû aux chaînes
d'information continue les grands
coupables de ce qui se passe en ce
moment
bien sûr ce sont les réseaux internet
parce que par exemple pour faire une
opération comme les gilet jaune il ya 20
ans il fallait faire un communiqué le
faire signer le porter au siège du parti
en question
c'est ça avoir besoin mais c'est bfm en
premier c'est à dire ce sont des gens
qui ne vivent que sur l'actualité de
vous les voyez d'ailleurs le matin où il
se passe rien ils sont là il fait beau
il fait pas beau il ya un attentat me
dire on voit tout le monde sourire ça y
est c'est reparti ces scandaleuses que
fait bfm je vous le diront c'est
scandaleux c'est scandaleux leur manière
de travailler
et puis les mots des journalistes
lorsqu'il y regarder ce malheureux
fillon a eu pendant toute sa campagne
électorale 15 personnes qui jouaient du
tambour tous les soirs devant ses
meetings
c'était sur bfm manifestation non sans
personne c'est un attroupement nuance
votre honneur donc il ya des mots il ya
des mots en français pour dire la valeur
des choses et par exemple l'interview de
l'interview d'apathie hier est ce qu'on
a besoin de passer est ce qu'on a besoin
de passer ça est-ce que ça a un sens 100
personnes dans paris du temps que je
faisais le journal télévisé 100
personnes dans paris c'était une brève
ou aof
qu'est-ce que ça devient aujourd'hui ça
devient des sujets est aussi et seat et
tous les journalistes pas simplement des
chaînes d'info en continu pour faire
leur beurre c'est aussi les journalistes
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont plus chercher
leurs informations soit à l'agencé
france presse soient eux mêmes par
rapport aux gens qu'ils connaissent mais
ils vont sur les réseaux pour voir ce
qui se passe sur les réseaux ils
raisonnent de ce qui se passe sur les
réseaux
voilà donc notre propre vision et dans
un très mauvais état et je le répète bfm
est largement responsable de ça pour
gagner de l'argent on passe toute la
semaine les mêmes interventions mais ça
intéresse les gens là des millions il ya
de l'audience quand même donc les
téléspectateurs sont devant leur écran
c'est normal qu'on qu'on leur rapporte
l'information oui ou non nous ne sommes
pas obligés juristes de rapporter
n'importe quoi avant les gens
s'intéressaient aussi à l'information
mais nous avions une responsabilité
notre responsabilité c'est pas de passer
n'importe quoi regarder l'autre fois
quand les dix élèves ont été mis les
mains sur la tête il ya dix ans de ça on
en aurait même pas parler il y aurait
une photo ou huit jours après
éventuellement dans dans le canard
enchaîné ou dans je ne sais quoi dormir
mais pas mais pas là là c'est devenu la
gestapo dans les dix minutes
ces scandaleuses il ya une augmentation
du volume des informations qui est
scandaleux je le répète elle est
scandaleuse et elle déchaîne elle
déchaîne chez les viégeois une aile et
qu'est ce qu'un sportif du team hm qui
est pas justifiable je veux dire moi
j'entends ce que vous je serai qu'à me
le cocasse que ça soit moi qui défendent
les journalistes et des faits dans cet
objectif que les trois autres personnes
mais objectivement moi je dis oui je
vous rejoins sur le faire que les
réseaux sociaux ont des effets
déflagratoire c'est une évidence sur la
hiérarchie de l'information
on sait qu'aujourd'hui une fête news
elle va cette fois plus vite qu'une
vraie nouvelle parce qu on est dans une
société du spectacle très bien c'est pas
nouveau mais ça s'est amplifié
aujourd'hui que les réseaux sociaux les
chaînes d'information ont une part de
responsabilité mais là le problème qui
est posé un problème beaucoup plus
profond qui est pas le problème de bfmtv
je suis désolé je reprends le sondage du
cevipof
2 il ya 23 % des français qui ont
confiance envers les médias on va vous
mondial jouera sur moi qui suis au parti
socialiste il ya que 9% des français qui
ont confiance envers les partis
politiques donc parfait vous faites le
commentaire du graff p our lives était
patent un bon ami mais soulève le
problème il est là c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on est dans une société dans lequel les
médiateurs quels qu'ils soient n'ont pas
la confiance des citoyens et ça c'est
pas un problème d'un journaliste ou
d'une information ça serait tellement
faible si c'était que ça je pense que
c'est quelque chose de bien plus grave
qui donne aussi à voir l'état de la
société française et je ne crois pas ce
que c'est seulement par le fait de
stigmatiser bfm tv ou un autre on le
réglera se dit aujourd'hui il ya un
sujet lourd qui est la façon dont les
journalistes repenser leur métier parce
qu'avant c'étaient deux
que venait l'information aujourd'hui son
concurrent c est donc ça nécessite
certainement leur plus de contenus
éditoriaux
ça c'est un vrai sujet il ya une
question sur la façon dont on éduque à
l'information
c'est un vrai sujet mais gère là dessus
à londres sur des choses un peu plus
fondée que ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
et quand il ya des journalistes qui sont
attaqués quel que soit quelle que soit
je veux dire leur point de vue c'est pas
normal et ça ça doit être condamnée
fermement et ce qui arrive est d'accord
ce que j'entendais d'une certaine
manière que bfmtv traité mal et donc ça
pouvait justifier voilà on entend les
négociations il sur trec issue retraite
il sur exposé les événements parce
qu'ils en vivent ils ont besoin de
gasoil toute la journée comme disait ma
maman avec une cerise ils font avec
l'afld outils je veux dire c'est ça leur
problème c'est ça la laissez pas united
c'est le système peut bien le problème
c'est que il ya ce déferlement continu
d'informations mais il ne rime pas avec
diversité des opinions représentées et
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on entend
beaucoup chez les jets les jaunes c'est
qu'ils ont l'impression que peu importe
il ya un flux toute la journée mais tout
le monde pense un peu pareil et nous par
exemple les jets les jeunes à qui on a
parlé ils font remonter ça notamment à
2005 avec le vote sur le référendum
européen où ils ont eu le sentiment
qu'il y avait que le camp du oui qui
étaient représentés gd un exemple parmi
d'autres un léger les jeunes par exemple
il cite aussi l'élection de diminuer de
la crau il ya ce côté pensée unique qui
est aussi reproché il ya mon avis fait
aussi partie des mois je suis pas
certain qu'un jour ce discours de pensée
unique
aujourd'hui je le qui est souvent vécue
comme étant la pensée droits de
l'hommistes universel de du quartier
latin si je vais jusqu'au bout de la
gauche bobo faire quoi bon si non
franchement je voulais
moi j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils soient
majoritaires dans les médias aujourd'hui
c'est à dire que franchement
ben oui je vous le dis franchement je
veux dire quand vous voyez est facile on
parle de bfm de ces news etc
si clairement annoncé pas mon sentiment
vraiment droite comme ça je vous
l'accordé
voilà sur l'europe sur les berges et les
directions sur le débat est quand même
très difficile et une charge
émotionnelle chez les journalistes
chez certains journalistes étude menée
chez certains médiateurs qui sont
toujours minoritaires et qu' ils sont
finalement victime d'une pente et qui
serait objectivement c'est un sentiment
j'entends déjà les jeunes on parle des
français on ne parle pas d'eux des
journalistes en tant que victime en
parle justement de vue du ressentiment
que peuvent avoir certains français à
l'égard des médias les journalistes ne
sont plus aujourd'hui dans l'analyse ils
sont dans la réaction mais ça je vous le
dis donc forcément ils sont dans un mode
dans une mauvaise passe et je lis je le
regrette beaucoup je dis moi j'ai connu
une époque où les journalistes n'étaient
pas dans ce système là dans ce système
là ils pensaient par eux mêmes et il
n'allait pas de chercher leurs
informations sur les réseaux ou sur
autre chose
il allait à la recherche de
l'information et je sais pas si les
journalistes n'étaient plus respectées
dans ces années là qu'aujourd'hui mais
en tout état de cause leur démarche
n'était absolument pas la même lors des
marches n'était absolument pas la même
mais moi j'ai 50 ans que j'aurais eu
derrière moi et je parle puisque je
connais un tout petit peu sans vraiment
le connaître on vous a posé la question
sur twitter trouvez-vous la méfiance des
gilets jaunes à l'égard des journées à
l'égard des médias justifier d'être 59%
à nous répondre oui voici quelques
commentaires sur lefigaro.fr olympique
nous dit en france la haine a été
déversée par tous j'avoue que je ne
comprends pas je vais avoir 60 13 ans et
je n'ai jamais vu ça anti mac le dit
pour moi aphatie a bien réagi allusion
évidemment à la à la vidéo convient de
vous passer
zahi nous déplore que les journalistes
n'aille pas au fond des sujets nicole
nous dit ne pas tout mélanger bfm est
allé trop loin dans le support au
président d'autres sont plus critiques
dans les analyses
alain partage ce point de vue est dit il
est clair que bfm est très injuste
vis-à-vis des gilet jaune
c'est un point de vue brownie tôt nous
dit la méfiance de l'esprit critique
sont légitimes
la paranoïa et le complotisme non et
puis enfin ce commentaire de charlie
intéressant qui me dit je lis beaucoup
la presse étrangère elle ne traite pas
les sujets différemment sur les gilet
jaune elle est par exemple bien plus
sévère que la presse française
et puis un dernier commentaire celui de
monsieur babineau c'est beaucoup plus
complexe
on l'a vu avec cnn durant la campagne
trump voilà ce que les médias doivent se
remettre en question effectivement si
allen qui était ouvertement hostile à
donald trump
alors on a vu jean michel aphatie qui
était un peu un peu désarçonné en tout
cas au début par rapport à ce
journaliste anonyme qui se définit comme
gilet jaune
et bien si jamais ça lui arrive d'être à
nouveau interpellé comme ça il peut s'il
le souhaite prendre exemple sur bernard
tapie qui a eu affaire à la même
personne et regarder comment il s'en est
sorti
que vous soyez entendu avec macron pour
pas perdre votre procès par exemple
n'est rien d'autre que me cause rien me
demander c'est pas vous promettez qui a
pas eu un appel avec macro que vous
n'êtes pas là de quoi qu'est ce qui vous
fait dire ça est-ce que vous lui parlez
dette qui d'abord pour eux de parler
comme mais parce que macron c'est un
petit peu un petit peu le tapis des
années john me parler comme je suis à
george en lice de rue un gilet jaune
monsieur j les jours pourquoi ça vous
dérange allemand quand on se lève je
dirais quand ils sont moins cons parce
que vous êtes quand même vous avez une
voiture italienne cessez vos amis de
mafia
voilà ce qu'est un grand moment si
effectivement d'être violent nous dira
qu'on passe des images qui les mérite
pas forcément mais après tout c'est
vendredi
adrien matos et qui sait ce journaliste
anonyme la wii il ya alors jans vite les
gens qui sont curieux à suivre le compte
twitter de vincent glad qui est
journaliste à libération et qui a un
petit peu enquêter sur le personnage et
alors ce mot m'échappe mais c'est un
ancien paradis qui alors moi j'ai
regardé l'ensemble de ses interviews qui
est un adepte de dieudonné complètement
antisémite pour le coup et voilà qu'ils
qui s'amusent depuis quelques jours à
guetter toutes les célébrités à la
sortie des studios télé maxime
d'égailler ce que d'une manière générale
vous sentez cette cette agressivité
cette fois ci entre les médias et les
institutions c'est à dire que il ya
aussi des gens qui disent les médias
sont trop peu moi par exemple on me
reproche de trop soutenir les gilet
jaune
est ce que cette tension elle est
générale les choses autrement est ce que
vous par exemple vous la sentez dans les
relations que vous pouvez avoir en tant
que responsable politique avec les
médias ou est-ce que ça se focalise
juste sur ce dossier précis ce que je
vous dise que j'ai recueilli
l'indépendance de la parole de
journalistique elle a toujours été mises
en jeu
dans notre pays on est ici au figaro
j'ai cru comprendre que le figaro
quelquefois était perçu comme un
journal d'opinion et voilà qu'il
l'assumé partiellement d'ailleurs mais
qu'il l'assumé et donc quelquefois
peut-être un peu trop conciliant avec le
pouvoir en place bon donc ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est pas nouveau la
question qui nous est posée c'est le
pluralisme d'abord et je crois qu'on est
enfin il faut quand même remettre les
choses à leur place on est dans une
démocratie est évidemment il ya une
concentration de certains médias de
grands groupes qui est préoccupant enfin
on est quand même dans une dans une
société pluraliste et avec des médias
plutôt pluraliste et il ya donc ça c'est
comme la question pour moi là qui sont
centrales et après l'autre sujet qui
nous est posée c'est c'est là la tension
qui existe comme je le disais tout à
l'heure avec l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires
je crois qu'on est dans une société qui
est très fragmentée dans lequel il ya
plus de d'intermédiation en tout cas
toutes les intermédiation sont mises en
jeu et elles ont leur fin et il ya une
part de responsabilité par ces
institutions qui ont certainement pas
toujours agi comme il le comme il le
fallait mais que ça soit les médias que
ce soit les politiques que ce soit un
grand nombre d'institutions et moi
j'étais vraiment très inquiet et très
frappé par le sondage que vous avez
publié ce matin
on voit aujourd'hui qu'à une société qui
a acquis dans lequel il faut qu'on
retrouve de la confiance et la question
de la vérité est un sujet central
aujourd'hui parce que tout est discutée
et c'est aussi le problème c'est que
rien n'est légitime donc vous êtes et ça
c'est grc rennais légitime et parce que
en permanence aussi on se contredit géré
quand vous avez le gouvernement qui est
pour reprendre le premier point de notre
discussion qui a quelques semaines
décide de revenir sur les décisions
qu'ils avaient les premières décisions
qu'il avait prises en faveur des gilet
jaune alors même qu'il avait il avait
quand même pris un engagement solennel
jeu si vous voulez comment voulez-vous
derrière que c'est gilet jaune il
considère que ce qui est dit est acquis
et donc là dessus il ya un vrai travail
je crois et j'espère que le grand débat
permettra d'avoir des solutions qui
soient des solutions à la hauteur de
tout ça il ya un grand travail pour
retrouver de la confiance de notre
société et et ça c'est une
responsabilité qui incombe à la fois au
gouvernement à l'ensemble des
responsables politiques et aussi mais
aussi aux médias
mais il ya aussi des choses qui sont
fait objectivement le service public
est capable aujourd'hui de pouvoir avoir
une une
les chaînes qui ne sont pas des chaînes
d'information d'avoir un traitement de
l'information qui me semble un peu plus
approfondie donc je je je dis qu'il faut
pas être caricaturaux non plus alors je
pense du la population et des dix jeunes
en particulier il ya le fait de
sentiment que les politiques n'agissent
pas avait réellement ou bien ne tiennent
pas les promesses lui dire non par
exemple table françois hollande qui
avait fait devant le congrès de
versailles a été pour le vote de la
déchéance de nationalité il l'a pas fait
alors que tout le monde était d'accord
pour le faire 99% des français
ensuite sur l'immigration aucune
décision n'est prise
bruxelles s'occupe de la taille de nos
fromages et nos vins mais ne s'occupe
pas de ça les gens ne sont pas bêtes ils
ressentent ça ils ne ressentent que leur
vie quotidienne n'est pas pris en charge
par pas par ses hommes politiques ou
tout au moins et les pris en charge
pendant les campagnes présidentielle et
puis après il se passe rien regardez par
exemple on va en parler dans quelques
instants mais la loi sur la sur la
suppression des allocations familiales
pour les pour les familles des enfants
qui sont en difficulté déjà il ya
quelqu'un qui est venu en disant oui
mais ça ne sera pas possible si la fa si
la main la mer est toute seule avec ses
enfants la plupart des enfants
délinquants sont ceux de familles qui
ont été séparés donc voilà déjà la
décision algérienne voire carrément par
les dents dans quelques instants la
dette confiance envers leurs élus locaux
donc je pense que attention à ce qu'on
dit il aime le léger pourquoi parce que
patron vous êtes contre la fin du cumul
des mandats
ah non moi je suis paul dont cumul des
mandats parce que je pense que chacun
non moi je pense que c'est d'ailleurs sa
série ghost débat pour très vite maxime
regaieg et danse dans votre raisonnement
il me semble que je corrigerai quelque
chose je me permettrai c'est que le
problème c'est pas que les politiques ne
s'occupent pas des gens c'est bien
souvent il n'assume pas les
responsabilités qu'ils prennent et quand
vous parlez de la question de l'europe
par exemple je veux dire on vient on dit
bien souvent c'est la faute de l'europe
pour ne pas avoir à assumer les
décisions qu'on devrait assumer et donc
il faut que les politiques assument les
responsabilités et les décisions qu'ils
prennent et je pense que la démocratie
ils ramenèrent 6
maxime n'est gagné pour compléter ce que
nous disait adriana tous les nos amis du
figaro.fr qui suivent de très près le
déroulement de l'émission apporte les
précisions suivantes sur le compte
twitter de vincent glad donc un confrère
de libération
il est indiqué que le journaliste gilet
jaune qui a filmé aphatie est tapi dans
la rue s'appelle marc griefs qui c'est
un paparazzi ce qui explique qu'ils
trouvent si facilement les personnalités
daniel bilalian avait fait la transition
pour moi donc c'est parfait on va
maintenant parler des
élèves violents acquis c'est un projet
qui revient régulièrement
on pourrait vous exactement où